we've been following the slow turn of
former Trump personal lawyer Michael
Cohen away from Trump and to quite
frankly law and order and cooperation
with the rule of law and in a stunning
turn of events we've now learned that
Michael Cohen secretly recorded Donald
Trump talking about payoffs to a playboy
model named Karen McDougal
who by all accounts had an affair with
Donald Trump and this is fascinating for
a few reasons first of all Tripp
specifically called the allegations
about the affair with Karen McDougal
fake news and lies and now he's on a
recording discussing a payoff to her
secondly the revelation that Cohen has
this recording of Trump obviously opens
up the question of whether he has other
recordings of Trump as well and for a
while I've been saying that if anybody
is positioned to take Trump down it's
probably Michael Cohen and the FBI now
has this recording if there are other
recordings the FBI likely has those as
well and Rudy Giuliani one of trumps
newer attorneys has swooped right in
with maybe the least believable
explanation which is that yes Trump did
talk about paying off Karen McDougal but
he never actually made the payment and
Rudy Giuliani is also defending Trump by
saying if he also didn't know he was
being recorded although I'm not exactly
sure what the relevance of that part is
I guess Giuliani's argument is if Trump
doesn't know he's being recorded then
he's not hiding anything because he's
telling the truth he doesn't think it's
on tape I don't even really get the
point of that and I know that the Trump
is don't even care about this at all the
trumpets claim to be about law and order
and honesty and the religious one's
about being Jesus like and all that
stuff but the pattern of just
straight-up lies lie after bold-faced
lie is disgusting and the affair itself
was called totally untrue during the
presidential race the campaign insisted
and hope Hicks insists that they have
quote no knowledge of any of this it was
quite literally called more fake news by
Trump himself so the primary issue here
and I know that we're gonna get some
emails from people saying David why do
you care about the affairs of
politicians I thought you didn't care
about that that's not the issue clearly
Trump had men
Affairs in his prior manner at marriages
in this marriage and and that's for him
to sort out with Melania Trump I agree
with that the problem is the hypocrisy
of rules for others that don't apply to
us the hypocrisy over the lying itself
given how much Trump slammed others for
their supposedly the inability to at any
point just say hey you know what I did
it and I'm sorry I did do it and I
didn't tell the truth and I'm sorry it
isn't just reflexive in the moment lies
these are calculated planned
orchestrated direct lies about basic
knowable facts and this is why they
simply cannot be trusted about anything
including whether Trump is jeopardizing
the national security of the country and
this connects directly to the attack on
media and a free independent press that
we've been seeing part of why Trump
hasn't been and won't be held
accountable for the lies is because of
how successfully they framed the lying
fake news media as part of the problem
and even frame the media as an American
and the enemy of the American people as
we talked about earlier in the program
when your entire followers when your
entire follower base doubts whether
anything about you that they read or
hear in the media is true you get away
with the lying and you can get away with
the insults and the deception because
fundamentally the Trump Ascan always
fall back on it's not clear any of this
stuff is true anyway because we can't
trust media to tell us the truth and
it's a very dangerous form of
gaslighting and if that's not a term
you're familiar with at the micro-level
gaslighting is like you constantly tell
your girlfriend that she said it was
okay to do whatever it was you did even
if she didn't do it right and you do it
enough and eventually she actually
starts questioning man maybe I did say
it was okay for him to do that stuff and
I just don't remember it
this is macro gaslighting that is going
on I heard it on the news but Trump
insists it's fake and bad and that the
news is the enemy of the American people
maybe I can't believe anything that the
news reports to me and this is what I
want to talk about next the concerted
effort
to turn the American people against one
of the most important institutions of
our country a free press by gaslighting
and saying the opposite of what is
actually true today's program is
sponsored in part by fruit or the tour
is a social forecasting game where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
open up the game on your phone or web
browser you'll see a whole range of
forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real-world
events using fruit oars in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube this
week on food tour I created the question
will Trump's average approval on five
thirty eight.com dip below 35% before
the end of July 2018 what do you think
go to future to make your prediction and
you can sign up now at fruit or calm and
start making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm